[Music]
I'm not perfect and you know I'm just
very blunt open about all those things
Amber Rose has always been candid about
her body and now she's spilling fans in
on life after breast reduction surgery
and when she gave you an update 34 year
old model appears to be loving her new
body and she's ready to show it off on
Sunday Rose updated her Instagram
followers on how she's recovering post
procedure after dropping five bra sizes
I don't know if you guys know but I was
like a 36 eight and I think now I might
actually just be a d-cup
which is like really small for me
earlier this month the model shared her
wish list with her surgeon naturally the
first thing Rose checked off her list
was some retail therapy I've been online
shopping and getting like cute little
shirts and both strapless little things
and I'm just so excited Rose also
revealed she underwent another treatment
getting rid of her cellulite the
bruising and the swelling went down a
lot and you know once I feel up to like
you know kind of moving around a bit
more out to you know I'll show you guys
my legs and my butt every woman has
cellulite
I definitely do